since eddie redmayne has now stated he
believes it was a mistake for him to
play a trans woman in the danish girl i
have a distinct feeling that the
conversation about whether or not cis
people should be playing trans actors is
going to come up again broadly speaking
so here's something i want people to
remember
no matter what justification or argument
you wish to make about why you think
it's okay for a cis actor to play a
trans role whether it be because you're
making a best actor for the role
argument whether it be because you are
saying well it's the only way the movie
will get made you need a big name and
there aren't enough big-name transactors
or whether it's something else this is
what i want you to remember
these decisions are being made by cis
people in the absence of trans people we
don't have a seat at the table we are
not having a say in this at all so
whenever this happens
it is cis people telling trans people we
know how to tell your stories better
than you do let us do this and
no
no you don't
include us